You were offered a million dollars to do Playboy,
so equal opportunity in the idea to monetize this moment.
Why did you choose to say no?
I realized that I can do so much more.
And not to say that, I mean, Playboy,
they have beautiful pictorials, they call it,
you know, pictures-
Yeah, you know, I did it.
I can't wait till my kids see that issue,
it's gonna be great.
No, I'm sure you look beautiful.
Super psyched about that.
I'm sure you look amazing.
But they're beautiful.
Hm, yeah.
I was really free back in the day.
That's what I was joking about on the nudes, I was free.
And actually, it's a smart magazine.
I think Playboy is a very smart magazine.
Their Q&A is amazing.
Look, it's a great institution.
And we can have different chapters of my life,
but I totally agree with you.
I am a very chaste,
proper pillars of appropriate mother now,
and I'm not gonna lie to my kids.
I'm gonna say, that's why I am, because I tried everything,
and I found out that ultimately being a good girl
is where it's at.
But our histories are our histories.
And we cannot hide behind them.
And I so respect that you don't hide behind yours,
and you're out there advocating for women now.
I applaud you for that.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
In fact, would you please tell us
about the Lorena Gallo Foundation?
'Cause I just think you are so amazing.
Please tell us about that.
Yes, I created the nonprofit organization
which is called Lorena Gallo Foundation
to basically expand awareness against domestic violence,
sexual assault and marital rape.
And I reach out to communities
and I engage the community through activities that we do.
And those forums are amazing
to actually continue the education
under name of Lorena Gallo Foundation.
I really admire you.
I love that you have taken your life
into a direction in service of others.
I love that you are fierce, you are a force,
you own your past, you don't deny it.
You are brave, you are strong,
you have a sense of humor, but you have a mission.
Yes.
Thank you.
I truly, truly respect that.
And I really thank you for this.
Thank you so much, I appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
You are so awesome.
You can hear more from Lorena in "Lorena: Escaping Bobbitt"
airing Sunday, April 24th on Reelz.
And also check out the Jordan Peele documentary,
the four-part series, that is just phenomenal.
And you can find out
how to help survivors of domestic abuse.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
to get Lorena's actionability and plan
of how you can participate.
And also, may I say something else, please.
There is a movie about it, it's called
"I Was Lorena Bobbitt" by Lifetime,
and that just win an Academy Award,
in the Canadian Award, the cinematography.
So it was basically a recognition of domestic violence
that is in the country as well, and around the world.
We will put that on our website too.
Thank you so much.
So much going on.
(upbeat bright music)